it's scary behind you Jake yeah there's
like a black void back there been
watching too much Last of Us
yeah man
that means I'm gonna play something dark
and oh
mysterious some brood ooh
[Music]
take me back to a simpler time the
legend of Jake's house
what lurks and the corridors
[Music]
and three two one ah
and in the episode after 30 seconds
hey are we doing this are we doing this
yeah we're doing this oh we're doing
this okay we're doing it all right hey
everyone welcome back to the quarter
digital podcast
thanks for being here yeah thank you I
hope you're having a great day and uh
we're just about to kick this off so
what episode is this one
of the episodes that is a certainty yeah
we got Jordan Nick Jake and myself Ren
here woohoo hell yeah brother
yep just living the dream
thanks for tuning in I mean yeah yeah
I'm the yep guy if you need confirmation
every good podcast hey every good
podcast needs a yep guy yep yep
wait give him a room yeah give me some
space
yep that's what I do
I don't know visual effects At All by
the way no when I when I asked for your
help for the ants video I was just like
I don't I don't need any simulations I
just need a yep man yep yep
yeah
it's contagious yeah yeah you're coming
for your job but it's it's it's not as
easy as it looks you gotta do it no
matter what it's stressful
do we have a do we have a topic today or
are we just no no we do we do Ren oh we
do okay Ren has a beautiful topic right
that I'm personally very excited today
he's like Nick my topic for today it's
gonna make your mind melt yep and it's
gonna run into the gutter and
cockroaches are gonna eat it oh he said
exactly that was weird I was there so so
I'm like okay like I literally was like
eating noodles while you said that to me
yeah but I've been waiting so what's
this awesome topic oh snap everyone's
looking at me I was just thinking we
could talk about ants maybe I don't know
I don't want to talk about ants I mean I
don't know I I my life has been
completely absorbed in ants for a little
while so I'm kind of okay not talking
about ants to be honest but that being
said we also just put out another uh
true scale video and that was about how
many ants are in the world and that was
a fun one to make yeah that video turned
out really I'm really happy with it yeah
it was really uh the the simulation of
the ants in the city that took things
over the top and I'm glad we did a
little breakdown on crew cuts to go into
that further yeah that was that was a
whole journey in and of itself yeah
that's that's one of those things where
you don't really anticipate the time
it'll take to like iterate and stuff but
I think we had like three was it three
days yeah about from start to finish
which you know depending it is fine for
a liquid simulation like that but like
at the end of that uh video which is on
the corridor website you can see it at
its proper scale at its proper speed and
it looks great yeah it looks awesome so
you know naturally like the nitpick in
me and you know I'm sure Ren too like oh
we look at we look at the super
close-ups and we're like ah it doesn't
hold up but our forgiveness came in the
form of it illustrating a point and it
doesn't really matter that the quality
is not like I think we're preemptively
like already crapping on the effects of
that video
and what happened to the oh sorry go
ahead sorry well I mean yeah no the the
effects I think were pretty dang solid
throughout but the simulation of all of
the ants above La specifically had these
glitches to it that were kind of
unsolvable uh at the stage we were at in
the process
uh because of some technical stuff you
can check it out on crew cuts yeah
basically what it came down to is that
the simulation was so large like liquid
simulations in particular already like
hold up a lot of disk space you know on
hard drives and whatnot and at the scale
we were trying to simulate stuff at it's
not that like the scale of the
simulation made it larger it was the
fact that the scale made it take longer
to actually Splash right like if you're
dropping something a few feet off the
ground onto the ground it's going to
fall pretty quickly but if you were to
scale that up so that the distance it's
falling is like a mile it's gonna take a
long time for that thing to drop a mile
yeah it'll accelerate quickly and all
that stuff but you know you have this
whole thing now it's it came out to a
simulation that was over 4 000 frames in
length yeah and that comes down to right
it's the idea of we have the city model
of La we simulate using that as the
collider but we don't have a firm grasp
on where the camera is going to be we
don't know when in the simulation we're
going to use it's it's all just kind of
free-floating because we didn't want to
like narrow ourselves down to all right
we're going to have this be the shot and
this other shot be the angle here and
then it turns out that the simulation
doesn't actually look good from that
angle it's like yeah so we wanted to
have the simulation itself Inspire the
camera angles and and the camera moves
and whatnot so that couldn't really
happen until the simulation had been
done and since that's going on in
Houdini but obviously the rest of the
lighting the rendering and stuff for
rent is going on in c4d we ported it
over via an alembic sequence which means
we're cashing out every single frame as
its own geometry for the entire 4000
frames so that Ren can kind of pick and
choose the areas and the angles that he
wants which works great which worked
great yeah totally but it's like there
are some limitations in that that take
place there's like every single thing is
like in an Ideal World we would know our
coverage we would make a separate flip
SIM for that coverage or at least fine
tune the mesh for that it could live and
be rendered in Houdini like all these
different things that would result in a
nicer mesh and result and run under and
whatnot but and you had to move on too
you had to move on to rock paper
scissors yeah moving on to to you know
the AI
um short that we're doing so yeah as
compressed as time was it's like I'm
still really happy with the SIM I love
watching it the shots are great too from
from its proper distance but yeah I mean
we could I mean I don't know how
interesting it would be to get into the
the signs of flip Sims and stuff but
yeah I'm happy with it at the end of the
day it sells it sells the the idea of a
pile of ants and Jake you you made this
final this final uh this final render of
this or this final version of this
simulation was six and a half terabytes
well that is the accumulation of several
versions of the simulation too yeah okay
also I think Jordan just has like things
that are a big hard drive space usage I
do enjoy it makes me feel like a big man
I don't think he accidentally server the
screen cap running all night he did this
intentionally it's my version of a big
truck
when I come into the studio next week
I'm gonna delete things that's okay
it'll be gone yeah uh the whole project
file is like seven and a half terabytes
and over six and a half of those
terabytes are just the Houdini folder
yeah and the reality is the vast
majority of that six terabytes is the
alembic sequence because Houdini it
doesn't you don't need to cash it to
such an extreme degree and there's like
compression methods inside of Houdini
they keep it nice and tight but once you
commit to the alembic export you're
committing to a fat boy yeah three
different Sims three different Olympic
caches and each one was over a terabyte
yeah it's fun right and then all of the
other data going on behind the scenes
and all the Geo and whatnot my biggest
complaint honestly way more than the the
simulation stuff was just the quality of
the LA model that we have which was just
literally thrown together from a few
different things that we had made I'd
use basically Google Earth to create a a
photo scan of downtown LA but I found
this website called aerometrics I
believe that have very very high
resolution photo scans of all these
cities across the world uh several
around the us some in Australia they're
an australian-based company and they
have this really really nice model of La
like uh I think it was like five
centimeter resolution so like
anything that's like five centimeters or
so is uh actually making a polygon in
the final model so it's like very high
real world scale five percent yeah and
it was uh D lit meaning that there
weren't any like Shadows or highlights
wow baked into the model
so you can light it up and whatnot and I
reached out to them twice and they never
responded to me at all and I was
literally trying to be like hey I would
like to buy this model from you can you
tell me how much it costs it was one of
those things where it's like they don't
list their price online it's like
inquire for a price I inquired and they
ghosted wow they were pissed probably
they're like we specifically put all
this work into all this High detail it
this is this model is specifically not
for ants yet this man
and he wants to use our model for free
that's right yes I didn't even tell them
anything about that yet in the follow-up
email I did but I mean they they haven't
responded to you today no they still
haven't responded because we still want
to check my SPAM and everything I don't
know so it'd be nice to have that for
sure five centimeters but also then I I
finally found pricing on their
Australian cities and they're like ten
thousand dollars a piece so I was like
okay maybe I think we could make that
work no
it's the guy who doesn't have to pay for
it if you take the Australian city and
you flip it upside down can it be used
actually yeah for an American city or
that was actually something he had
already done he had taken the model that
I had had exported from from c4d for the
the whole city and I guess when you're
working with fbx files maybe it was done
in the export stage or perhaps on the
import stage on your side but you can
like flip the direction of the z-axis
and I think that got checked and so it
automatically got mirrored so you did
the whole simulation yeah on a mirrored
reality of downtown Los Angeles yeah and
then I solved it with like a little
single node that was like the mirror
note the mirror note yeah that's like oh
this is what we solved so all done I was
expecting that to go through a whole
overnight simulation oh thank God not
but yeah it's it's fun I I always love
those those types of challenges
um you know when you get a chance to do
something you're not like super
comfortable with but you have a limited
amount of time and at the end of the day
you gotta get it's the it's almost like
um the first time I heard it mentioned
was when people was talking about his
workflow and he's like I said a 45
minute timer I think it was on on
corridor's channel yeah and he's like 45
minute timer no matter what I post it
and I'm like I kind of like that dude I
kind of freaking like that because the
perfectionist in me could tweak it
forever oh of course but it's nice to
just get it out it is what it is I find
peace in it and we move on and I learn
some things and we're better for it yay
that feels like the story of my life
sometimes human growth yeah yeah it's I
mean that's that's what you do and then
you die it's it's a fun ride if you're
if you're open to enjoying the process
you know so I'm just enjoying the
process of that and that was a really
fun little exercise when was the last
time you'd done liquid Sims like what
was your experience before this I
haven't done a ton of them I did uh I
did one for to the death when the hand
gets cut off in a cross and the wrist
squirts out blood and that's a pretty
fun one and then I did it with Fenner in
um accurate Storm Troopers when Han
Solo's head explodes oh sure and that's
where I really learned about reseeding
and you know receding just to keep it
short is like Houdini makes additional
particles to fill in gaps so that you
know you're not having any like holes in
your mesh it's used for all sorts of
different purposes I didn't really
understand it
um at the time so I had it pretty high
and it adds volume obviously because
it's filling in new particles and uh the
head would explode and there'd be like
16 heads worth of Blood by the time the
Sim was done so uh like you know just by
trial and error and and some awesome
tutorials online you can kind of dial in
a look that works for that shot take the
lessons learned and move on to the next
thing because there's also that rated R
Spider-Man video oh that's right that's
right yeah yeah Spider-Man's body
exploding which someone commented on
that and said that it wasn't
anatomically correct to which I reply I
know yes no it wasn't it wasn't at all
it was just a bag of blood and that's
okay sometimes what you need visually is
a bag of blood ask Quentin Tarantino you
know yeah dude I I had I actually it's
it's weird thinking back on it now that
as one of the earlier things I learned
how to do because it it was not early
when I learned it but I learned how to
do liquid Sims and real flow back in
2014 it was whenever we're doing Shadow
of Mordor I did all the yeah the blood
hits for that movie those were great
yeah that that yeah that for that movie
yeah that official trailer
automatic trailer yeah uh and so that
was me learning how to do fluid Sims and
you know just chopping up Orcs and all
that stuff and I did another one a
follow-up it was one of the YouTube
videos we'd done uh gun game the gun
game ultimate gun game video where uh it
was like the the chainsaw bayonet on
from Gears of War sick like maybe it was
sawing down no it was on Sam I think and
it was like blood going everywhere
hitting the lens that was I think the
last time I did like a liquid scent yeah
done lots of fluid Sims since then
because smoke and fire counts as a fluid
right
yeah and if if you guys are okay with
getting a little nerdy here uh flip Sims
are really interesting because they are
they're different than every other type
of simulation you have the the fluid
Sims I watched the video this morning
can I explain it oh shoot hit me yes
okay so a flip Sim
has both uh simulations that pass each
other in the night and also that don't
interact with each other no that's
particles
part yeah I know they have that's what
he said is that what you said Okay a
flip Sim has both yes yes particle
simulation whereas which passes other
particles and does not interact it just
says yeah they just they just say hi and
they go they go on their way and then
the other kind of Sims which contact
each other and explode I think what is
that a physics sim volumetric polymetric
a volumetric volumetric fluid it's a
fluid Sim yeah okay all right that was
just mine
so I mean in essence that's true it's
like particles don't see each other you
can just emit them it's great for Sparks
it's great for all sorts of magic
elements and and snow and rain and all
that fun stuff you do particle I I
always call them particle systems that's
totally the easier way to sort of think
about them differently it's a system not
a simulation yeah even though there are
like some Physics stuff going on gravity
wind resistant stuff like that yeah trap
code particular is an example of a
particle system interesting okay CC
particle World CC part of the world oh
my gosh yes yeah like I mean so many of
our videos uh are you like even in the
ants video there's that shot at the end
where all the ants are being shot out in
the space using the that was trap code
particular that's a particle system it's
great and I mean it's super lightweight
and like you're dealing with points that
don't need to track because everything
that you track in a simulation it needs
to that weighs something like every
attribute that you're tracking the age
of it the life of the particle the
weight the mass the anything the that
you want to track takes up space and you
know pop Sims particle simulations are
really lightweight in that way you can
tell them to be aware of their neighbors
that takes extra weight but if you're
trying to do a like a fluid or um a
liquid simulation using just particles
it takes so many sub steps it takes so
much effort it's just not worth it at
the end of the day and you can also do
liquid simulations with just volumes but
volumes have ironically the issue of not
retaining their volume when they
separate like chunks fly off they'll
shrink away and just disappear and
there's no way to keep them and so the
best balance is actually taking
particles and taking volumes and
essentially the way it works is so cool
it's like you've got 10 million
particles right all in this like dense
little thing and they have a velocity
for their next step in essentially the
next frame of of movement but before
they're allowed to move their velocities
are converted into volumes and in the
volume realm I almost view it as Shadow
of Mordor right The Wraith world the
upside down world we we see the inverse
and we see things we can't see before so
when we drop into the volume World we've
got velocity vectors and the main goal
is non-divergence this is the flow what
do you mean by non-divergence
essentially all these velocity vectors
they don't want to be Divergent they
don't want to run into each other
because that's not how Water Works it
all flows together if two streams meet
boom it finds the area of least pressure
and push is there it's this blurring
almost a velocity to us to a single
Source okay and so all those velocities
in this volume will look at each other
and go the look look at me and they'll
all know they're there and there's this
idea of pressure it looks for where is
the least velocity existing let's aim
that way and then it sends that velocity
information back to the particles they
move one frame oop and then back to The
Wraith world and we look now we continue
to blur and that's how it works every
single frame they're dipping back where
are we back up dipping back and so you
don't lose the volume and you have
proper flow and you have non-divergence
and then once you have all your
particles done you mesh it and you got
your liquid and it's cool it's like I
don't know who thinks of this stuff it's
like the coolest thing in the world man
so yeah anytime I get a chance to mess
around with that I'm like yes please
it's so cool so yeah yeah just a little
bit of flip science for you interesting
yeah I love it super fun love that
and if you haven't seen the crew cuts
episode guys what are you doing here
come on click the link in the
description head over head on over to
Corridor Digital yeah this morning too
yeah yeah exclusive show now in its
third season are you not aware of this
you guys are aware
you're unaware you're yeah right are you
talking to us for the viewers yeah yeah
I'm talking I'm talking to you I'm aware
of course yeah I've heard of it and
you're you're aware that there's that
there's we're now in its third season of
crew cuts our exclusive that is nuts and
I will say Jonah and Austin have been
killing it with like the mograph
elements yeah they're great they're
they're super helpful and yeah really
wants to have like a new like intro card
for every episode yes they're really
working hard on that I love it I think
it's great it's super fun they're going
hard with that this year
sustainable but I it's I love it I like
it so far their heads are available so
yeah it's working
well Nick and I thought of another
um idea that may require some more
physics simulations quite possibly even
another flip simulation that's fun we
don't know yet but Nick should we spill
the beans on this idea I think you
should because I forgot which idea
you're talking about no we had like a
huge meeting today and we thought of all
these different ideas and now I just
can't think of the specific one because
there's so many good ones oh man I heard
you guys laughing on the phone yeah like
something's Brewing it's VFX artists try
recreating dude perfect trick shots
unsatisfying render oh it's kind of true
yeah no you're right yeah it kind of is
that but like we're specifically like
taking this idea of the VFX forensics
right so we've been working on this
video a little bit of backstory I think
we talked about it actually a little bit
you might have heard Matt talk about it
but we're doing this like video all
about the effects being used in car
insurance uh sphere of like of Law and
like these these firms will hire VFX
companies to take all of them exactly
take all the factors that contributed to
a crash all the data photo scans
pictures like weather conditions like
freaking like metering the road like the
concrete density to figure out like how
much friction the tires all the crazy
stuff and then they enter that into a
really old crazy program and you know
then and see what they get and see if it
you know actually holds because like in
theory you can definitely like reverse
engineer accidents and stuff like that
because you lift up like let's say
there's a there's an accident in the the
car door gets broken off and slid across
the ground and it's like okay you can
lift up the car door you're like it
weighs this much you can figure out the
center of Mass on it too so and and the
the coefficient of friction on the door
coefficient of friction on the ground
and you'll be like okay it's x amount of
feet away from the car accident that
means it had to have had this much speed
going into this which means that it had
to have had this much energy injected
into it from somewhere else and you can
see the deflection of like
the the hood or whatnot like you know it
takes us it's a very specific amount of
energy to bend stuff and break stuff and
we already know what those amounts are
and so if you look at how much something
bends or breaks you can determine how
much energy went into that and also
determine say how fast a car was going
when it hit something wow or how fast
something else I guess that's where it
would get confusing right is like we
know this this speed was required but we
don't know how fast each one was moving
which could be actually a problem in in
um the court case because it's like how
do you prove who was moving fast
kids and like oh of course that would
help too like the damage on the chassis
of the car because they have like these
like car models that are supposedly
accurate to the actual construction and
like like brittleness and everything's
like calculated so you can can actually
hopefully finite element analysis yes oh
dude it's insane but like there's so
much data we need for that video like
the video has been kind of on the back
burner right now because we're waiting
on like legally clearable data that we
could use for our video where we want to
mess around with this data and see what
we can do with it yeah in like a more
like Cutting Edge VFX program and
they're super excited about it it's just
like these things are real car crashes
yeah like you know so we need to get one
cleared or get a test but this idea of
like trying to recreate Dude Perfect
results and see like how hard actually
is it to fake these yes I mean it's hard
to do them for real obviously but is it
even harder to fake them yeah some of
these things are just I mean it's it's
one of those things where you can like
because we've done this a few times for
videos and the portal trick shots video
specifically and and the the follow-up
little short uh that I made of that too
whereas like you just take a a ball and
you give it like this much velocity in a
certain direction and you hit go and you
see where it lands and because it's a
computer you can replicate that exactly
every single time so then you just put a
basketball hoop where it lands I'm
saying you're like how many times would
it take you to hone that in if the hoop
was predetermined you know like yeah
maybe it's like one of those things
where you have to have the the ball
bounce at least three times okay and
you're not allowed to alter any of the
or like where the the hoop is or
something like that and you have to use
I want to actually take one of their
videos that like take one of their most
popular videos
and do and use that as our constraint I
love it I love this idea so so that way
we can do like a side by side
with our physics Sim and and their shot
from their video
and it did you don't have to like
texture and make the 3D environment nice
but we will have to build a 3D
environment and
so that you can actually do the the test
one of their videos that is like I mean
some of their videos they've done
multiple of these now they're very very
like popular where they like are up at
the top of a stadium and they throw the
ball way out and it just keeps falling
and falling crazy that's something
that's really difficult to simulate in
the programs that we use I'm not saying
it's impossible but like that's sort of
like spinning aerodynamics thing is not
something that the software will use
even Houdini is really like set up to to
solve yeah you'd essentially have to
calculate for the mass add some like
force coming from the other side that
will eventually steer it in a certain
direction but that no honest it's more
than that like a ball spinning creates
lift oh I don't know how to do that
that's exactly I can't hand animate I
don't know man uh see I think I forget
who is the awesome people I forget the
Australian dudes and veritas and they
dropped like that ball off of a huge Dam
in Switzerland and the one where they
just dropped and they go straight down
one way they just give it a little bit
of Spin and then it spins and then just
starts going outwards wow and it's
literally because of like the way it's
spinning is creating lifts above it and
is able to kind of just drag it further
out that's cool and that's a very
complex sort of physics Behavior that's
occurring that I mean you can fake it in
like say Cinema 40 or Houdini by just
being like throwing and turn on Force
here and then turn off and turn on some
force that way and and you eventually
kind of get it looking the same and
that's that that's part of that is that
you would make it look like that that's
very possible and that's why it would be
nice to actually just use something that
they already did because then you have
perfect reference you know I mean like
you have exactly but are you actually
simulate eating it at that point I don't
know that you would be I think you'd it
would be a mix of everything at that
point whatever sells we got it we gotta
get the right video where where all we
need to do is like you put in your
physics parameters and then you hit you
hit go first take first try yeah yeah
and you say first take first try and
then hit it and then see if it gets it
then go to lunch for an hour wait come
back and then watch it there's also the
whole idea of sub steps too because you
know simulations they they occur every
single frame but stuff happens between
those frames and so if you end up
getting janky results you increase the
sub steps so between every frame let's
have 10 steps that it calculates to give
you a result one at a time so it's like
basically simulating 10 frames between
frame 0 and 1. and you can make that
50 100 5 000 sub steps which now you're
doing a 5000 frame simulation just to
get one frame of data yeah because
reality is an infinite number of sub
steps reality is the best man infinite
resolution you know no lag mainly mainly
sometimes my brain's a bit slow to wake
up but hardly ever lag hardly ever lag
but um as far as the dude perfect stuff
that actually is a core memory of mine
from visual effects is the first ever
visual effect shot that I put on YouTube
was me throwing a basketball backwards
okay and making it through the hoop you
know simple comp job
and I called it the world's farthest
basketball shot thinking it was cute and
fun because I was a kid and I put it up
and I got a comment that day
that started with an f and ended with a
G
and I took it down the next day and I
didn't go on YouTube for a while it
messed me up so I would be very happy to
trick that person
give us the opportunity give me the
opportunity for like a nice character
Arc moment yeah let's let's get let's
let's redeem those Junior High you know
for young Jordan mean comments yeah
let's get it
we got we gotta find the right video if
we find the right video I think we don't
over complicate it
everyone gets a shot you know the best
thing about the Dude Perfect videos too
is you know there's I think there's five
uh like core hosts of that show yeah
five dudes so everyone gets a shot you
know everyone gets to do something in
the video and we'll just we'll just
mimic the the same format that they
applied where everyone will have a role
I love it everyone will try can we can
we do it like literally shot for shot
their video where we wear the same thing
but it's Corridor merch instead of Dude
Perfect merch and we just match each of
the shots but do it with a visual
effects instead like that's so fun
oh my God
that would be great I wonder if it's
worth reaching out to them because uh we
met some of their teams yeah no we're
friends with uh like we know their
production team yeah we should
definitely hit them up because maybe
they'd be willing to a contributable
reaction yeah and they seem like yeah we
yeah we helped him out with a video that
they did a while back
um where they were trying to do you know
remember like two three years ago early
green screen virtual production stuff
where people were trying to figure out
how to get you know
footage to display on a green screen and
then have that come through in camera
and how to capture that we helped him
Ren help them figure out how to do that
and that's cool so yeah it'd be good to
reconnect with them dude perfect is just
such a fascinating sort of Empire to see
because like every one of their videos
is like they're very well made and they
just get a tremendous amount of
viewership
of such a efficient like production team
and just they're constantly like making
stuff and
so are they still a top 10 YouTube
channel they've been in the top 10 for
years yeah how many they have 60 million
subscribe
but still they which is a weird
statement to say
yeah 58.8 still crushing man every one
of their videos like three weeks ago 8.2
million views one month ago 12 million
views one month ago 10 million views wow
and they're building a they're building
a like a stadium a theme park a theme
park or something on Epic scale yeah
it looks like a freaking sci-fi uh like
Spaceport type thing it's just a it's a
theme park you go to in every game no
matter what you win like you get you get
the basket every single time you're like
I literally it's impossible I'm not
exactly sure what it's trying to be and
what it's gonna be or whatever but like
it's it's centered around the idea of
trying to do trick shots you come here
and try to do trick shots fun oh my God
bunch of other stuff too yeah it's it's
an attraction yeah there's a bunch of
stuff to do I don't exactly know what
all the most popular videos water bottle
Flip 2 is their most popular video guys
ever 430 yeah
431 mil all we need to do is simulate a
water bottle guys come on
it's a very interesting simulation you
have a lot of factors going into that
because yeah because it's fun this okay
this is an age-old simulation problem in
visual effects do you simulate the
bottle or do you simulate the the liquid
inside the bottle first because which
one comes first because it's like yeah
because the water pushes the bottle in
the air yeah no not exactly I know
there's probably way to do it people
simulate boats floating on water but
then you get that simulation down then
you lock that simulation on the boat as
an animation and then you simulate the
water around it
do you know what I would do I would
honestly just film it's a bottle flip I
would hand animate the bottle to match
the bottle flip and then I'd throw the
flip fluid inside well that'd be the
move but see I knew it would involve a
flip Sim hold yeah you're looking over
here Jake let's go the water might not
behave correctly because it's within a
vessel that is immovable that's what I'm
saying so the the the mass and uh
inertia of the the water inside of it or
I guess the momentum of it pushing
against the the bottle should normally
move the bottle but if it's specifically
animated a certain way it has the
potential of like bouncing off of that
and then you have water splashing
against the other end of the the bottle
but the bottle which is more or less
weightless continues to flip as if the
water is stuck at the end of it because
that's how the bottle flip works is that
that would be interesting to see age-old
question the age-old question what Sims
first the chicken or the egg
found it
a little slushy chicken that's another
thing I'd like to do
around that the container of their fluid
guys came first
but yeah there's also one ping pong
trick shots three Okay pink I mean ping
pong that Circle physics
go yeah it's cool absolutely it's
everybody it's everybody's dream to do
what they what they've done
yes starting with backyard trick shots
and they have okay the more you wait
seriously the more you make Nick the
more you make the more like you you
stage up the Empire that is dude perfect
so like you start with like you know a
show on on cable television and then you
have like a live tour and then now now
the ultimate one is you're building a
theme park yeah no yeah so how do we
take it further
country
[Laughter]
that reminds me of god dude buy a series
buy an island chain and turn it into a
country
when we did the the first first take
first try thing we're trying to like
shoot cars or something like that with
like Nerf darts this is like early days
and it was like we would say first take
first try even though it was like there
was a nerf trick shot video we did was
that the video specifically I was like
Nerf trick shots I think that's one
first take first try got big
I remember doing a jump 360 shoot I hit
I hit the cards nice eventually
first take first try yeah
we used to do some wacky Challenge
videos oh my gosh I went down a rabbit
hole the other day the thermal camera
hide and seek that might actually be
like one of my favorite quarter Crew
videos like older than two years ago
content like it's so good what was that
what was the premise for that we just
had a fleur camera like a thermal camera
and we like blacked out the whole studio
and like half the crew hid and then like
Sam Clint and Nico took turns being like
this agent who would go around basically
try to find them with thermal camera or
they could get you know shot by a Nerf
gun yeah the video where Sam was what
was his name first class Sizzle Wizzle
Sizzle
he's he is a connoisseur of heat lines
and uh he's yeah he's one of the best
boys on the force that's awesome it
never fails back up laughing if I'm
having a bad day I'll just load up
Sizzle Wizzle dude that first shot when
Sam's standing there with his helmet
around is like it's not even his chin
it's just around his like under his lip
strap you're just so stone-faced
and that reminds me one of these days I
I will do the the
blanket on the Splinter Cell the
Splinter cells sticky cam
IRL oh that was awesome I remember that
yeah back in the day when we I started
getting into fpv that there was like
these tiny little uh little drones that
were like this big and they had these
tiny little cameras on them that were
Wireless and
I just remember thinking oh man I could
package this up into like this little
projectile with the camera facing
backwards and get on like a little
slingshot or a little Canon like a
wristband Cannon like stick around a
corner and dude that's really cool
never pursued the video yeah that idea
is like an old friend that you see once
a year yeah
his friends now
lots of it I mean Nerf Drone 2.0 will
happen at some point
it's been on the books for years
so stinking fun that's such a great
video that's the friend you you both
keep canceling on each other you're like
hey sorry maybe next weekend but when
you see each other it's like you never
left yeah it's a beautiful kind of
friendship we actually already started
filming the video with nerc we filmed it
that's the start of it last year
literally it's been a year now yeah and
I'm sure the tech has gotten a lot
better so maybe we won't be using the
same drone since then why why the weight
is it just uh schedule wise enough I
mean a little bit of that a little bit
of uh there's a lot that needs to happen
for this video and I've just not devoted
my full-time trying to figure that out
that's fair enough it's like
videos don't make themselves yeah yeah
gen one was just released is it from no
no uh no I just saw the trailer
yesterday and you still need to input
footage gen 1 is uh Runway MLS cool
um AI like video video generator
essentially yeah I'm from what I saw
it's like you put in your input video
you give it like a style frame or some
text and uh it'll generate it on top of
the video but that sounds a lot like
just image to image with d Flickr
applied to a sequence kind of look like
there's that much D flicker though I saw
some results it's pretty flick the
claymation oh yeah you saw that you saw
the clay Mission yeah that one was so
good that's cool though I really enjoyed
to see how the exactly the general
public reacts to the animes uh rock
paper scissors video I I think because
I'm desensitized to it now I've seen it
so much obviously because it gives a
conversation happening about how like AI
art is not art and if you're doing that
shame on you uh you know Netflix came
out in
or rather it came out that Netflix has
an anime show that a lot of the
backgrounds were being generated from
using Ai and there's a lot of backlash
over that because of course as usual
there's a lot of missing understanding
about how stuff happens but like anyone
who is to like sit down and look at how
this anime video is being made here no
one can actually make a good argument
that it's not real art yeah that's
probably the most value we have in that
that BTS video but BTS is just to like
show like how intensive this process is
not even by AI just by all you guys yeah
as artists
yeah here's the here's the gist of it is
that it allows us to make something that
would have required a lot more people
previously yeah oh yeah and that's all
that's all the creative technology we've
used since the dawn of chord or digital
has always just been
we're using this because if we don't use
this we we need a lot more people and we
don't have a lot more people yeah it
just what we're doing right now isn't
any different than that
yeah it's it's just it's just people I
don't know I guess it's just because of
the whole like use of the word
artificial intelligence even though it's
really just a fancy program yeah I'm
annoyed by just like any other is this a
misnomer yeah
it's not even yeah I mean I guess it has
yeah it has machine learning it is it
even right so yeah
yeah end of the day it's really it's
just a it's a story that we couldn't
have told without it so it's not it's a
nice tool for that for like setting us
up to do something about it you know it
just would have taken you way longer
because you would have had to use other
methods to create the style yeah which
wasn't possible which wasn't really
immediately available for the size and
scale of our team prior yeah 100 100 so
but yeah I like run said a ton of
artistry goes into it like without the
Artistry side it would not be in any way
shape or form watchable to any degree it
would be you'd be off put by it very
quickly
um so yeah it's I'm excited for that to
come out I'm excited for Nico to like
start telling you guys about it because
it's it's really cool and as blown away
as I was when he did the storybook that
he made dude yeah with the initial like
stable diffusion models and I was
shocked by how advanced it was like this
is gonna do that again on a bigger scale
Tony Stark it's it's really hype it's
really nice
um he's been like Iron Man one Tony
Stark yeah yes so true
hey uh he he'll hit me up every Monday
him and me and Sam have a call before
the Monday morning meeting and the last
like three of them has just been Nika
going hey so
um okay so is there anything else I have
to do like before I can work on the
videos
dude his only focus has just been like
his ultimately his question is just that
it's like okay uh okay this is what I'm
gonna work on before this podcast I
asked Nico if he wanted to be on this
one he was like oh man yeah I could talk
about some rock paper scissors is it too
early to talk about it it's not I guess
it is better to talk about once it's
already out and I was like yeah I was
thinking maybe we could like talk about
antsy he's like okay well in that case
now I'm gonna pass on the podcast yeah I
was like Nico I'm gonna go do anime
yeah he's he's fully dedicated and it's
been cool this week and last week too
because basically the full Squad you
know has been dedicated to just that
like this singular Vision so it's we've
been ripping through stuff and it's been
a treat you know and again the final
result is gonna like it's gonna blow
people away so it's it's really cool and
I'm hype for for that release which is
coming up shortly oh super shortly
speaking of the ants video though uh
most of the effects were done in the
last week of the whole project with most
of the renders happening in the final
like two days how is that possible Ren
so I was using this uh it's been around
for a couple years now it's called the
render Network it's kind of like Cloud
rendering but it's specifically for
otoys octane render and when I say
render I mean rndr and so the difference
between this and normal Cloud rendering
where you you know hire a service you
upload your file and it renders on a
whole bunch of computers on the freaking
Amazon AWS whatever uh this happens on
the quote-unquote blockchain fancy so
to sort of briefly explain how that
works it's like you know when you have a
computer that's hooked up to the
blockchain and it's mining Bitcoin it's
basically just running these complex
calculations and and stuff like that and
you get paid in Bitcoin for that as soon
as I'm not going to go into detail how
that works but
instead of mining Bitcoin what if your
computer was just rendering pictures
that someone needed rendered and that's
the idea behind the render network is
that you have this whole sort of
unbounded network of gpus just ready and
waiting to render out images for you and
so uh the otoys service uh the render
Network you upload your your scene file
you have to like bake it out to an orbix
file it's a bit of a thing and it
confused me for the longest time and
then on this project I actually finally
started using it and fortunately I had
the help of some of the people who
literally work on the team and they were
walking me through a lot of it and
there's a bunch of new uh tutorials on
how to do it these days
but it's a lot easier than I expected to
do and and it's like you export out your
scene you upload it and then you render
it out and it's so incredibly fast like
my computer has a 40 90 in it and it's
faster than 239 oh man in in another
computer and it's like it's a very fast
computer and I was having these renders
that were going to take like 8 to 12
hours and normally it's like okay you
get your shots kind of ready throughout
the day and at the end of every day
you're just like you got to make sure
you have a render going because you're
not gonna have enough time if it doesn't
go it's the most stressful part yeah
yeah and so that's always kind of been a
bottleneck in a lot of these videos is
that I just literally don't have enough
time to do the renders but with this I
was able to just upload it out and
continue working on a shot which is the
benefit of cloud computing in general
but
just the the ease at which it worked and
it's so much faster and more convenient
and easier to use than regular cloud
computing well you were saying it would
take eight to 12 on your machine but how
long would it take minutes literally
minutes I was having a conversation with
Ren when he started a render and I saw
that he was getting about it was about
12 minutes or so per frame and he had
100 or whatever frames 120 frames 120
frames 150. and in the conversation I
was having with him about it it finished
I could I was floored like it's very
very fast and uh and it's cool because
it actually gives you all the frames
laid out yeah so you can see every
single one and you can re-render
anything where you see an issue you just
send it right back you just click a
little button and it'll re-render it and
solve any issues with motion blur or any
problems that it has uh and give it back
to you and you can download it and run
with it immediately yeah it was really
cool now granted there's a couple
different like tiers that you can pay
for because it just it still costs money
and you pay for it uh with regular cash
now that's what they're trying to
encourage you like you basically hook up
a PayPal account or like a stripe or
whatever and then you just buy credits
like in-game currency and then you use
that but we were using rendered tokens
because it's an actual blockchain coin
and these coins have actual real world
value but
so I didn't want to use those coins but
they already tied to our account because
otoi actually gave us these tokens like
two years ago okay and when they're
trying to get us into it and I just we
didn't at the time and here we are two
years later and our account still has
those render tokens they gave us 2 000
render tokens at the time and at the
time they're like a few cents a piece or
whatever yeah now each of those tokens
were worth a dollar fifty at its height
though it was worth seven dollars
something like that yeah when all of it
yeah but everything was Sky High balloon
but yeah and of course right when I was
starting to do some of my most intense
renders the price had gone up to like
two dollars a token yeah and
so for some of the renders it was coming
out to like most of them was like 30 to
40ish tokens per render and that was in
economy mode and it would go up to like
140-ish tokens at like priority speed
and uh so that the first render I did we
were like wow rendered right in front of
me I was like that was a 300 render
yeah
you pay for you know I mean yeah that
was fast but I don't want to pay 300 for
this render that was literally it was
literally the end of the day and so then
I went home without rendering anything
on my computer because the render had
finished
had actually finished yeah and so I
could have just had it render all night
on my computer
um but again it was like that's why they
encouraged apparently it's significantly
cheaper like five to ten times cheaper
if you uh use real money rather than the
coins that's so funny but the coins were
already associated with our accounts so
what I couldn't do was sell those coins
for dollars and put those dollars back
into the account as credits no but
crypto is going to totally replace Fiat
guys okay it's gonna happen I swear it's
gonna be coming yeah so I don't I don't
know the specifics of why that's the
case at all but so I was like all right
fine I guess I got 2 000 uh
and then yeah and so I I'm getting
through I've by the end of the project
I've gone through less than half of the
the coins that I had so it was about a
800 or so tokens that I'd use to do all
of the renders for the whole video and I
had one last shot that I had literally
started on Saturday the day before the
video was supposed to come out and it
was just a close-up of some ants just
like twiddling their antennae and
whatnot uh it's it's literally 90 frames
long a three second shot and it's when
I'm in the studio here talking about the
two and a half million ants surrounding
me it was just this quick punching shot
I I packaged it up I said it wasn't even
a big file and I was like you know what
it's priority I'm gonna I got a lot of
money left I'll spend like 100 200
tokens on this shirt it'll be my little
uh
what do you call it in in Indulgence
yeah
and yeah a little Splurge it ended up
costing almost
780 tokens foreign
problem with using any sort of crypto
buy anything it's like you should have
held it yeah at least with normal money
I'm like yeah I know inflation will make
this more expensive like in a year but
it's not like but maybe I'm spending
twice as much yeah no I I do want to
point out though that that there was
something wrong with the project file
I'd upload I I don't know what I did I
optimized it how I had every other shot
and I don't know why I did render it out
at 4K with like 3 000 samples so it was
like like I said it was an Indulgence
yeah sure I'm gonna splurge on this
render but it shouldn't have because
that one render costs more than all of
the other renders my entire history
combined hmm is is the idea since
they're taking cash now for renders that
you still get paid in the render tokens
and you're just it's up to you to sell
them or honestly I don't care
what I do know is that I'm going to be
using the render Network for pretty much
all videos going forward from now on uh
yeah yeah it sounds incredible this
video was nice because it wasn't our
money actually funding it but like it
just makes too much sense to use it
going forward because if I can finish a
shot and have it done uh a quarter of
the way through the day and I could just
send it off to to be rendered in an
economy you know not priority unless I
really need it right now and then
continue working on it on a shot it's
nice because that was part of the
problem on the ants video was that like
we have three computers that are
specifically just for rendering we call
them our mastering computers and all of
them were being used all the time yeah
and yeah between anime or between uh the
Houdini stuff you're doing they're all
constantly being used and it was like I
I was gonna have to get in line behind
everyone else
so that's just like an ant just like oh
look at that yeah now granted towards
the end of it if I really needed them I
could have been using them and also I
did like the last couple days I was
actually rendering stuff locally because
of the whole
turns out trying to package up a file
that has two and a half million clones
of a high quality 3D model isn't that
quick it wasn't a big file at the end of
the day because it knows it's a render
instance so it's not actually
duplicating a model two and a half
million times uh but each of those
models does have a different position
and rotation element to it so it's
basically writing out an XML file like a
whole freaking spreadsheet yeah for two
and a half million things with six
attributes that are all different so
every frame because I also have all of
those attributes changing across the
shot and so it was taking longer just to
export the scene to an orbix file and it
would have just to render it out locally
on another computer yeah and that's not
necessarily A detraction from the render
Network that was just bad luck on my
part
yeah yeah I I can think of quite a few
instances before working here where I
was like up against the the deadline
wait what happened so I just think about
all these render things made me think of
a scale video idea but it's scary oh
yeah well all I was saying was uh there
were quite a few instances where like as
a solo freelance artist I was up against
like crazy deadlines for these various
projects and there were a few times
where I turned to uh cloud computing or
you know uh online render Farms yeah and
there's there's no greater feeling than
getting the bougie treatment and yeah
the money racks up and it costs you
everything at least it was when I did it
you know but to watch what would have
taken again 10 12 20 40 hours on your
computer just take away everybody else
is computer working for you man it's a
powerful feeling and it's nice to know
that it's uh so like a I mean granted
the render tokens costs yeah if had I
been using dollars most of those shots
that I were saying were like 30 tokens
so like roughly 45-ish 50 uh should have
only been taken like five to ten dollars
per render and that's actually an
affordable amount yeah totally that's
well worth it yeah
um I am curious though what your idea
was oh I want to see a video
where you show me the size of God's GPU
yes dude to run all the Sims of Earth at
the same time oh my gosh
2 million 80. I'm I've literally been so
fat dude I will sometimes like get super
close to things and just go like
infinite resolution yeah in like the
amount of simulations going on in this
room right now real time so many
playback
run that you can put the camera anywhere
hair Sims freaking muscle Sims are going
on right now liquid Sims in our mouths
yeah so I touched on this a little bit
of the stories
think of the stories we could tell
write it on the mouse Sim the true scale
of God's mouth says
[Laughter]
that'd be a funny video that yeah I
don't know
if you quantify it at all you've now
rounded to a an amount that is
technically not accurate so no matter
what you do it's never actually gonna be
accurate because of the evil concept of
infinity wow and what's crazy is as
you're making the video that Computing
requirement is growing because you're
making something new so it'll never be
up to date
there's always maybe you could frame it
more like like if human sight you just
kind of average like a resolution for
human sight and you're like if God were
to be running the Matrix simulation you
know how much GPU right it's like we can
all roughly perceive 120-ish frames per
second if we're our adrenaline's going
maybe it's upwards of 300 frames per
second
yeah and what's crazy is there's no like
bump mapping or displacement mapping
going on like this is all real geometry
every little crease and crevice yeah
there's no texture mapping here it's
just raw geometry and Adam is probably
one polygon no because you can go can
you get smaller than an atom that's
that's the smallest oh dude no atoms get
it gets way smaller now I mean subatomic
particles
oh my gosh that's so good we're talking
about that's good stuff so subatomic
particles like uh protons electrons
that's the smallest and then it goes
smaller than that like smaller than a
proton or a neutron is like quarks
that's what of course like protons and
electrons are liter not electrons but
like protons and neutrons are literally
made of quarks quarks
and then you have things like bosons and
neutrinos and all kinds of things
is article that applies how much mass a
particle has wow it's and I think
basically it's like it's it's a
quantifier that tells the universe how
this particle interacts with that
Universe yeah isn't it like measuring
the space in between the particles or
something like that it's like it's like
we're hitting the edge of my knowledge
of particle physics here I'm not it well
next week we're going to talk all about
the Higgs boson okay I thought I thought
quarks didn't always consistently appear
and like within a Proton or Neutron like
I thought they like disappeared and came
back
I mean I I don't know if that's quarks
specifically but like there's a there's
like 12 I think different types of
quirks and there's quantum entanglement
so it's like you have some quirks that
do the exact same thing as other quirks
orbiting
a nucleus wait it's not like in the
textbook with the little no it's like an
electron an electron is like a is like a
field yeah
someone's watched my video yeah
but but in the textbook it looks like
it's orbiting it but that was a 400
textbook I want my money back have I
ever told the story about how I I lost
my thermodynamics textbook no because I
stole a poster from the restaurant wait
what wait so many questions
you were thieving when you were going uh
about your studies I don't know if
anyone knows being a hooligan at
Portland State yeah no University of
Portland big difference oh sorry
um it was like it was the District 9
movie poster was up on the wall like
every week they uh at the University of
Portland they would have like this movie
showing in like the whole week leading
up to it they would have this movie
poster and it wasn't the commons it was
I forget the name of the it was like
this restaurant where you can go and
like buy lunch or snacks or whatever
Student Center
yeah yeah it was like it was like a
small little thing like that and it was
at the end of the night on like the last
day they were gonna have the poster up
and I really wanted this poster
and so I waited till one guy I was kind
of waiting next to the door one guy
walked out and I like did that thing
where you put your hand in before the
door closed and I went into the
restaurant the lights are out and I just
I pulled the poster off the window and I
was like I'm like yeah and I I go like
jogging out and everyone's sitting
outside of the the restaurant doors are
just like looking at me like
yeah and I roll up to the door right as
Public Safety is pulling up and they're
like walking into the doors and I just
immediately turned around and walked
back and I just sat down with everyone
else who's on there everyone's just like
and I'm like I just pulled out my
thermodynamics textbook and I'm just
like oh I'm standing here they just kind
of like walk around they locked up the
door and they was like no one doing any
poster stealing around here
they paid to have that taken down
tomorrow morning yeah oh yeah it looks
like everything checks wait a sec and I
was so nervous like in hindsight I had
nothing to fear yeah I've gotten a lot
more used to those situations
um
you shouldn't see his bedroom man it's
covered
uh I'm not I'm not big on sting I'm not
I'm not suggesting I steal normally I'm
more of a trespassing kind of yeah yeah
for sure uh but like
I was so nervous that I just stolen this
District 9 poster and I I was like
trying to play it off with the textbook
that when they finally left I just got
up and left with my poster leaving my
250 dollar thermodynamics textbook on
the table there in front of me
and I came back the next morning because
I realized that the next morning that my
textbook was gone and it was it was
already gone dude so I tried to make it
through another like few weeks of the
semester without a textbook and I was
starting to really struggle and so I
ended up having to pay all that money
for another textbook
on your District
see kids
crime never pays people and that's like
the most like
that story is going to date you bro yo I
committed a crime to possess a physical
copy of one image
I will say though if you say you're like
what Grandpa you mean this on my phone
if if you're Jake if you're saying crime
number pays I disagree because those the
price of those textbooks is Criminal and
they're profiting true I mean how about
that take that that some some could be
said for that but also you don't have to
buy them
I tried that route and it didn't work
granted this is also like I graduated
college in 2011. so this was around 2010
I think and the movie came out I think
2008 or so it was like already out of
theaters in that on home video uh they
they probably bought the DVD and were
playing it I would always use a reseller
to Vibe I would never buy my Texas news
no I would buy them they'd say hey we
want this version of money you know we
would get ver get the ninth Edition or
whatever but it's like the eighth
edition is the same thing and it's a
hundred and fifty dollars cheaper yeah
the problems like you'd get homework and
you just have like hundreds of these
like sort of math equations and problems
that you would have to solve and those
would change between additions of course
and so you'd be assigned a set of
homework and if you don't have the right
edition of the book you're just doing
the wrong homework I see yeah no and it
is I agree it is overpriced and criminal
and that's the reason why I started this
uh my library because I was paying so
much for these damn law school books I
was like well I'm not gonna get rid of
them now dude I know exactly my
textbook's up on a shelf now as well
where I'm like I'm keeping these forever
I don't care yeah I'm never gonna look
through my calculus 2 book ever again
but I'm not giving that thing away
like I hate to say it but like we all we
all kind of think you're like a little
bit uneducated about calculus bro yeah
we have been talking about it have you
really been told I actually was thinking
it was third of a day I was thinking it
was thermodynamics actually
Jake okay we gotta like break it one at
a time to him okay okay sorry I don't
know
anyway man maybe just piss him off you
know no I think I have like one textbook
still it was jansen's history of Art and
that thing cost like 300 so yeah that's
crazy the worst is when the professor
makes you buy yeah when the presser
makes you buy the book that they wrote
oh dude that sounds the craziest thing
it's like wait what
I'm unaware of the fact that it's a
whole [__] racket yeah by the way I
just like the whole thing it's like you
have a college student they're out on
loan they need the book you're gonna
they're gonna pay they're getting their
student loan money so they're gonna pay
whatever amount of money they have to
pay for the damn book because you know
that that's the book that they need and
you're just gonna hold them over the
coals because you know you can and it's
backed by the US government signed
stamped and certified that's basically
America honestly it's like how do we get
this person to pay all this money to me
with all the money they don't have that
they borrowed from America it's because
when you're in college I don't know
about you guys but it didn't feel like
real money oh no no no it's made up it's
like this guy has never had a paycheck
to yeah it's like significant this guy
signs the thing he's like sign this he's
like yeah don't even worry about it
taken care of and you're like okay cool
I'm gonna go to a party I'll take three
I get money disbursements yeah they're
called disbursements that does remind me
of James Cameron though I recently
watched an interview he did with Howard
Stern the week before Titanic premiered
and Howard Stern was like you know this
was it was very I want to watch the
whole interview because the Howard Stern
was asking him about like how do you
learn filmmaking and like how do you get
away with like doing these big movies is
like I mean I'm not making any money on
Titanic he was like he was kind of just
like I this is my last foray into
filmmaking because no one's ever going
to give me money again like to make a
movie whoa and then you know turn around
Titanic was the biggest movie of all
time
uh but
he asked him how he learned filmmaking
and basically he was saying because he
was a truck driver uh before becoming a
director and what he did was he went to
the USC or I forget which maybe it was
UCLA I forget it was a it was a school
here in LA and he would Xerox textbooks
and he would pay for the cost of
xeroxing and it was just you know a
penny or page or whatever maybe penny
for five or ten pages I don't know but
he was just like Xerox like dozens of
books and he would have like huge stacks
of just Pages uh with in binders and
whatnot and he said it cost him like 120
for a college education oh my gosh it's
like 120 just for some photocopies
that's a lot of money but then when you
think about it in that context you're
like
yeah that's a great idea
Goodwill Hunting when he's like telling
the guy yeah the only difference is that
I got the same education you could have
got for 3.99 and late fees at the local
library only you paid 60 grand for it
it's a great accent like that yeah yeah
where's this
is my Bostonian
the town too get ready Town two hey Ben
let's get over here
to make come on get over here you
handsome bastard come on let's make
another movie
I just saw a trailer for a movie that
Ben Affleck is directing
about Nike Air it's about like Phil
Knight uh the CEO of Nike The Oregonian
and the start of the Michael Jordan shoe
the first shoe
that's very interesting literally like
started a whole freaking movement dude
legit and it's like uh Matt Damon uh
Jason Bateman are in it nice a few other
people
um I'm intrigued I love basketball well
did you know Fenner went to the freaking
Clippers game last night what lucky wait
hey the clip was uh
surprise like his friend called him up
was like hey you I got a Valentine's Day
gift for you want to come with uh me to
the the Clippers Warriors game oh that's
awesome and we won too Clippers won I
mean I'm more of a a Warriors fan than
Clippers fans so this is not news to me
uh you know I'm like one of three
Clippers fans so it's all good yeah it's
uh
was supposed to go Fenner was supposed
to go on a date with his girlfriend but
then his friend called him and took him
to the Clippers game cause I got
something better I think priority yeah I
don't know yeah
yeah well all right so maybe we can
maybe next time we can talk about my
journey this year to slam dunk a
basketball yep yes
the yep guy yep all right yep
ran that sounds like a slam dunk was all
hurt he's like did you just yup me dude
you never get up someone in a podcast
dude my first one will race to the year
is this Sunday oh that's exciting I'm
excited
hurt yourself
there's so far zero bone breaks this
year yeah for everybody don't jinx it
don't don't say that dude yeah
yeah we're all bracing ourselves for red
yeah I never get hurt actually racing
it's just five minutes before the
awareness before and after
before and after all right I'm gonna
play us out people all right do you want
dark and mysterious or do you want like
yeah I'm feeling a bit uplifting yeah
give us something a little uplifted
into the first like homesteading Channel
and it's like the generic music you got
okay I'm into that oh yeah
[Music]
oh we're gonna put a good backsplash on
that wall
yeah tear right out there it is
gonna be a great place to raise our
family
everything's gonna be all right
all right yep
[Laughter]
so funny because I can't hear most of it
but I'm assuming it's helpful all right
so yeah three two one